but the story that i'm going to tell is
that they had a this guy was amazing he
had a bandaged head yeah and he wasn't
talking yeah and it's the same thing for
tate face who's now playing in uh in
vegas his act was he was kind of this
weird mime and and the magician was
created the mystery of him not talking
he he then he committed and said that's
i i think comics need to do that too
commit to their persona 100
commit not just specifically the persona
but to understand the environment
they're in but that's that's
that's the mistake i always say to the
comics you know i had a friend on
uh dan ederman who i think did one of
the funniest sets he had a great set
he's hilarious he's a hilarious guy and
what happened was he didn't he was
having discussion like this for whatever
reason simon said you know
i just didn't think that was funny
that's wrong and wait wait
it's not wrong that simon said he didn't
think it was funny no not that part
no dan is is a funny guy right dan said
you know
you um dan said listen i respect the
fact that you know everything in can
create music superstars but i think you
don't know comedy i i i think you
for you comedy you wouldn't know the
difference between your simon comedy and
your own [ __ ] wow or something like
that you've got to walk away for the end
of the night and remember things and go
you know what i saw and heard something
which blew my mind
that didn't
well
in the music business your opinion is
gold gold standard in in the world of
comedy
i don't think you know
your ass from your elbow i hate to say
right
and they they blew up and he went
upstairs i knew he was devastated and i
went and talked to him
and i said can i tell you something not
only was your act right but that
rebuttal
is going to be the standout and it was
in that moment that was on champions but
simon was wrong that's not the point
that that's the point of the snoop the
[ __ ] point of the story i'm not
talking about the point of the story
he's not talking about the point but not
just from
another thing i've noticed which i know
is kind of going a little bit off topic
is it's not only about the comic in that
environment for the comic i think it's
really hard on agt2 for the audience to
also understand
the pressure that's on comedians
you have to know as a comedian am i
getting b12 yeah do you want yeah
what else do i what else i want
something i was gonna say i don't feel
like you know the audience is always
saying like well look at these crazy
acts where they're flipping through the
air which is amazing and i don't think
they think that an amazing comic that
made the room laugh or even
brandon leaks your or your poet i don't
think they think that that deserves the
same kind of credibility because they're
just but i don't think that's the issue
the issue that i always tell people i
want you from sorry what is that what
does that mean credibility what does
credibility have to do with anything no
i'm saying that i don't know if the
audience sees the talent in what comics
or spoken word has to give because it's
one single person i don't know if they
realize that they put them so what she's
saying is they put themselves under more
pressure than is necessary just do what
you do but what i will say to any comic
magician singer anybody who comes on the
show start before you meet a hundred
percent and if you create a character
even if your character is yourself that
character
needs to always don't break that so my
question to you is as a as an advocate
for comedians and i i
you it's really nice watching you as a
judge
advocate for comedians i i
so it doesn't matter what anybody says
here's my feeling and i've said this to
everybody
first of all we are the number one show
on television as far as the sheer number
of people that watch what else would it
be pardon me where else would you
measure it
18 to 49 you know in the in uh
we're not the
you know
just sheer because people from five to
95 can sit down and watch
as somebody who's selling
you know their comedy or their music or
their talent
where
where on earth does that size audience
exist sure
[Music]
you